درع روسي تحطم في هجوم أوكراني
شرق العاصمة الأوكرانية
يدعي الآن أنه أوقف
هجوم روسيا ضد كييف.
لقد كانت معركة مشاة شرسة
واستغرق الأمر عدة أسابيع ،
وقد اعتمدت أوكرانيا أيضًا بشكل كبير على
طائرات بدون طيار حديثة ، حيث تم إرسال طواقم الدبابات الجوية للروس في كمين ،
حيث زعمت أوكرانيا أن
القوات الروسية بقيادة سيئة لديها المزيد من القوة البشرية
لكنها تتأرجح.  هجمات غير متوقعة
ونقص في الإمدادات
قد يكون ما يقولون أنه صحيح وفقًا لما
تقوله زينا كيلكو التي تعتني بزوجها الجريح
في مستشفى بروفاري القريب ، حيث
اجتاح الروس
قريتها ووصفت التعامل مع
الجنود الروس الذين كانوا يعانون من البرد والجوع وخرجوا عن
السيطرة.
قبعة سيدتي معطفي كانت حذائي
ملابسنا
جندي روسي قالت إنه
مخمور  لقد أذهلت ساق زوجها
ببندقية مسروقة ،
ثم قضينا يومين في الطابق السفلي
، قالت
إننا بدأنا في إيقاف تدفق الدم
وتقديم الإسعافات الأولية ، لدينا طبيبان ،
أنا قابلة وكان هناك ممرضة معنا
قالت  أن ضابطين روسيين
اعترفا لاحقًا بأنهما لم يدعموا
غزو بوتين
وأن آخرين ساعدوها على إجلاء
زوجها فاسيل إلى الخطوط الأوكرانية.
القوات
يرسل قادتهم
جنودهم إلى المذبحة ، قال إن
هؤلاء الأوغاد أرسلوا لتوهم إلى
موتهم ، والضباط لا يشفقون
عليهم ، حتى أنهم لا يحسبون خسائرهم
المدنية هنا ،
ووصل موليا إلى المستشفى عندما
كنا هناك
كان يساعد شقيقه ديميترو ، وهو
مربي نحل ، في حضور خلايا النحل عندما
سقطت قذائف روسية بينهم قبل ثلاث ساعات ، مما
أدى إلى مقتل ديميترو بجروح قاتلة عند
وصوله.  قال زوجة وثلاثة
أطفال إن هؤلاء ليسوا بشرًا ، بل إنهم ليسوا
حيوانات ،
ولا أعرف ماذا أسميهم
سام كيلي سي إن إن أفردك